je des pam ce député
je n'ai jamais eu de compte à l'étranger
ni maintenant ni avant devant un
hémicycle plein à craquer il dit cette
phrase et beaucoup de députés vont le
croire
la revanche sera d'autant plus terrible
c'est que les députés sûrement dans la
rudesse de leurs questions lui feront
payer ce mensonge devant la
représentation nationale
[Musique]
on est quand même dans le dans le temple
de la république et on a un ministre
ministre du budget qui ment sur son
compte en suisse
il a sciemment menti à la représentation
nationale
est ce cet acte inqualifiable c'est un
discrédit complet mais au discrédit il
ajoute le déshonneur
[Musique]
est ce que quelqu'un à l'elysée à
matignon
chez les ministres savaient qu'ils
avaient un compte en suisse c'est ce
versant politique qui va beaucoup animé
les auditions
jérôme cahuzac est convoqué devant la
commission extirpé de sa longue retraite
jérôme cahuzac on l'a pas vue pendant
trois mois depuis la passation de
pouvoir depuis qu'il a quitté bercy
il s'est caché personne ne l'a vu les
quasiment comme en cavale journalistique
je veux savoir si vous regrettez ce
mensonge il 5 décembre dernier je vous
ai menti en vous répondant monsieur le
député tout simplement parce que dans
les heures qui ont précédé
j'avais menti au premier ministre le
président de la république
toutes les chaînes vont retransmettre
les deux heures d'audition de jérôme
cahuzac
la force de l cpc de retransmettre
toutes les auditions ou presque les
députés vont auditionner mediapart
évidemment qui a sorti la sphère niveau
auditionner les ministres à christiane
taubira pierre moscovici mots associés
pour le machu président je connais votre
finesse sémantique est impropre john
cusack n'a pas été associé à cette
demande en quoi que ce soit le plus
virulent de tous c'est charles de
courson qui le président de cette
commission enquête vous pensez qu'une
réponse est crédible qui consiste à dire
je me souviens plus d'une réunion qui a
eu lieu en janvier de cette année ce fsm
né de cette amnésie vous ne vous paraît
pas crédible
ça veut dire que vous contestez les
propos de monsieur pierre moscovici
ça veut dire que nous n'avons pas les
mêmes souvenirs un peu différent
la sphère cahuzac et la commission
cahuzac c'est un marqueur de l'histoire
parlementaire si aujourd'hui un ministre
n'est pas nommé sent qu'on est épluché
son patrimoine
c'est parce qu'il y a eu la sphère
cahuzac et donc pour lcp avoir été aussi
présent sur cette affaire avoir pu faire
des auditions en direct avoir pu
décrypter tout ce qui s'est passé et le
rôle qu'ont eue les députés en étant sur
cette affaire et en d'une certaine façon
rendant justice aux français en posant
des questions que tout le monde pouvait
se poser de nous on était très content
d'avoir fait ça vraiment vraiment
content
[Musique]